republican senator bob Corker of
tennessee has had a series of clashes
with President Trump most recently on
the administration's muted response to
Saudi Arabia's killing of Washington
Post columnist Jamal Khashoggi the
chairman of the Senate Foreign Relations
Committee is now preparing to step down
first on CBS this morning I visited with
corker at one of his favorite
restaurants in Chattanooga to talk about
how Washington works or doesn't and what
worries him about the issues no one
seems interested in addressing my
introduction to public service I think I
was in my late 20s I started working in
this neighborhood the good things that
are happening in our country are
happening in communities and cities like
this as the thing about our current
president I don't think he I don't think
he knows that there are people all
across this country
but live in communities like this one
just wanting to be engaged senator
corker has tangled publicly with the
president from his own party the
president has great difficulty with the
truth can you support it the president
do you regret that now I'm well what do
you think where are you right now on
your feelings about this I like many of
the policies love the deregulation that
is taking place
I love the animal spirits that have been
released in our country obviously I'm a
Republican I love the number of judges
that have been confirmed but I think
what the whether president hurts himself
and hurts our country is his own
personal conduct it's unnecessary you
know it's it's an unforced error you
said the president tries to divide us I
think what President Trump the part
that's disappointing is that it's I know
it to be purposeful the distinction you
seem to be making is that this president
is actively being divisive for the
purposes of his own political success he
he might say that himself I mean I don't
I think that's self happening and so
when people say he's a little rough
around the edges he's got some tweets
that you may not like but he's passed
tax cuts there's no real cost to his
rougher side of his nature I speak out
because yes I do think there's a cost I
think there's a cost to our young people
throughout the country I think there's a
cost to just the way people are relating
to each other do you think you'd be able
to speak out if you were running for
reelection to run in the state of
Tennessee and to be publicly critical of
a president on the Republican side
especially one that has captured the
base in the way that he has would be bad
for your health is that the pressure all
your colleagues you leave behind face
I've been told by candidates who did
running in campaigns this year that no
one asked them about any issues to speak
out on our side of the aisle no issues
they want to know one thing
are you with Trump is that healthy I
don't think it's healthy no but senator
corker does see certain advantages the
unorthodox nature of the Trump
presidency has some in some ways caused
people to be closer on each side of the
aisle
in some ways still vast differences in
policies what make them closer well it's
sort of like everybody's in the same
boat right the same boat but he says
still unable to take a hard vote the
United States senators don't want to
cast a tough vote on the fiscal crisis
facing the country here's what happens
you're on is somebody will have them god
I don't want to vote only if we have to
vote on that then I like to take a
position on it and why we're hired to
vote I mean you know express yourself
and used to be the deficit was the
conversation it was the centerpiece it
was the focus and it seems to have gone
silent and and this has some real cost
we spend the entire year working on this
appropriations process which deals with
35% let's say of what we spend as a
nation and we don't spend a single day
on the rest of it which is what is going
to be our undoing
right not a day is spent on it that's
what you call majoring in the minors
it's just not on the American people's
mind and it's sad we're harming the next
generation the greatest privilege is a
crisis senator corker now won't be in
the Senate to help confront as he
returns home here to Chattanooga
so do you know exactly what you're gonna
do now I do not is the political elected
office stage of your life over
I would rule nothing out at this time
would you rule something in I know that
everybody every person thinks that every
senator wakes up in the morning and
thinks they're looking at the next
president I don't do that I don't I do
though think about it sometimes very
candid interview and I'm thinking his
restaurant has a nice fireplace
yeah well that was his house that house
that the fireplace the restaurant I
don't know whether they had a fireplace
or not but they had very good foods very
candid and open with you yeah he still
got a lot of energy he's he's not done
wouldn't think you think well I just
think he's he cares a lot about these
issues and he's not he's not talking
about working on his you know going into
the woodshop and just making some nice
decoy ducks or something he's got things
he wants to do there's another chapter
for sunroom worker